this is the magellan strait that
separates the south american continent
from tierra del fuego
it's often referred to as the end of the
world but also as the gateway to
antarctica less than a thousand
kilometers south of here we're on an
expedition with chile's science minister
to inspect 180 climate change stations
on the way we find the remains of a
beached whale
this is just a fraction of what is
covered by the southern hemisphere's
longest climate change observatory just
launched by chile so we have sensors all
the way from the antarctic peninsula all
the way to the atacama desert and will
use a single platform to provide access
to
the data
in
in a open access format
until now data from the southern cone
has been scarce
climate scientists say the new
observatory will provide badly needed
data to track changes in temperatures
radiation precipitation the direction
and strength of winds and sea levels in
real time
that includes antarctica which is a key
modulator of the earth's climate when
i'm sitting in my laboratory in my
office in the winter in australia i can
still be seeing what's happening in
antarctica because there are all sorts
of climate effects that happen when
we're not there
dr marcelo lepe is an expert in
dinosaurs fossils and climate change in
antarctica and patagonia where chile's
antarctic institute is based
i am actually touching a 74 million year
old femur of a dinosaur that lived here
in patagonia and most likely in
antarctica because at that time both
land masses were one it was one solid
semi-tropical jurassic park scientists
believe that learning more about how and
why dinosaurs like this one died could
be vital to the survival of our own
species
climate change experts insist that we
are at the stage where we must predict
and prepare for what is coming the key
words is mitigation and adaptation but
we still have time to produce
a behavior more
suitable with this new vision that we
have to adapt and mitigate the changes
in the in the in the next years
chile will launch an international
antarctic center later this year in
puntarenas dr lipa says that its
proximity to antarctica makes it an
ideal location for global scientists to
put their heads and data together to
anticipate everything from floods in
china to heat waves in northern europe
to drought in australia or chile
fortunately unlike the dinosaurs mankind
has the ability to access data and use
science to help mitigate what is coming
lucia newman al jazeera magayanis chile